all right good afternoon everybody how's
the conference going so far everybody
having fun
uh hopefully you've learned something by
now uh and uh hopefully you're here to
learn something more about microservices
and also hopefully you didn't eat too
many carbs at lunch so you won't fall
asleep on me uh but it's nice to see all
of you as you can tell from my accent
I'm not from around here so I'll try and
translate anything I need to in my talk
if I talk about lorries or lifts or
anything like that I'll make sure I
translate it for you my name is Jay
short for Jonathan Tower we're going to
be talking about not building a
distributed monolith how to avoid doing
microservices completely wrong
so I'm going to start with a little bit
of a story a couple years ago a client
of ours came to us at my company
Trailhead and said
we're just about finished building this
micro Services project that we've built
internally and we'd love to have someone
take a look at it
and maybe you can help us out there's
just a few little performance problems I
can see some Smiles on your faces
already you know where this story is
going maybe from personal experience
there's just a few little performance
problems with it if you could take a
look and figure out uh why these you
know a few endpoints in our apis are
slow and help us just really quick
before launch
so we said sure uh we're a consulting
company that's what we do so we said
sure we'll take a look at that it only
took a very short amount of time looking
at their code to realize that this was
not a small problem but this is a
problem with their whole application and
it was going to affect all of their
endpoints once they launched and it
wasn't uh a small problem in the
performance way either it was actually
going to be a huge problem because
instead of building microservices as
they had planned to do they had in fact
built
a distributed monolith
so this is the bad guy in our story
today this is the monster that I'm
hoping that I'm going to give you some
tips today to make sure that you avoid
building one of these in fact I want to
give you 10 of the most common mistakes
that I see as a software consultant I
work with a lot of different companies
many of whom have tried lots of
different architectures including
microservices architectures
and these are the 10 most common
mistakes I see them making and I'm
hoping that you can take these 10 things
and avoid these pitfalls in your own
projects
uh before we get started as a attendee
or a Watcher Online of this session you
are lucky enough that you get a free
offer if you have any questions about
the topics we're talking about today
microservices
software development in general like I
said I'm owner of a Trailhead of
Trailhead technology Partners we're a
software consulting company I've got
this free offer for you here you can
scan that code I'll show this again at
the end and I've also got some brochures
here if you're old school and you like
it on paper
um but uh that's basically for a free
30-minute consultation if you have any
problems that you would like someone to
take a look at
I'd be happy to talk to you and you can
check that out there a little bit about
me besides owning Trailhead I also am a
Microsoft MVP if you're not familiar
with that Microsoft MVPs are awarded for
their expertise in software and also
sharing that expertise like we're doing
right now in the community I've just was
awarded that back in the summer for the
eighth year in a row I also have some
contact info here if you want to get a
hold of me and finally at the bottom
I've got a GitHub link where you can get
all of these slides afterwards
so with that out of the way let's start
with some definitions make sure we're
all on the same page about what we're
talking about with monoliths and
microservices and distributed monoliths
let's start with the monolith we've all
been working with these types of
software applications for in some cases
many decades depending on how long your
career is these are kind of what you
would consider your traditional software
architecture this is when the whole
application is built together and
deployed together as a single piece if
you go change something in one place you
can't create the you can't build or
create the app without all of the pieces
being there together
so if you're maintaining a monolith you
might be familiar with this problem
but in a monolith sometimes you might
have something like a button that has
the wrong name on it and you need to
make a change to that button that should
be a very simple change right one line
maybe not even code one line of UI and
if you have a monolith you still have to
do an entire deployment of the
application right and a monolith goes
all together or it goes not at all so
that's kind of the idea behind a
monolith
um some of the advantages of a monolith
it's much easier to build than a
microservices architecture also
typically has better what's called Data
throughput so don't confuse that with
performance
performance is actually can be in a well
architected microservice can be better
we'll talk about that what I mean by
data throughput is that when somebody
types something in and submits it on a
form in the application from that moment
to the moment that the entire
application knows about that updated
piece of data that is kind of considered
data throughput so in a monolith
typically you're going to have one
database you're going to have everything
compiled together looking at that same
database so the moment you've updated
the table where that data goes the whole
application knows about it you can do it
in a transaction so that no one else
accesses out of
out of date data but it's getting the
most up-to-date data all the time so
that's one of the advantages of a
monolith another Advantage is that it is
scalable so you might be thinking well
I'm here in this talk to learn about
microservices because I heard that those
are more scalable and I'll say that I
can confirm that microservices are more
scalable if they're done correctly but
that doesn't mean monoliths are not
scalable right there's still things like
load balancing and data sharding that we
can talk about
uh there's also fewer cross-cutting
concerns when you're building a monolith
versus microservices we'll talk a little
bit more about that as we're getting
into the details here today
and the most important difference in my
opinion is something called immediate
consistency anybody ever heard of the
term eventual consistency when it comes
to microservices oh good okay so about
half of us so this is I think the most
important point I'm going to hit this
several times throughout the talk but
this is a really big difference between
monoliths and microservices there are
disadvantages of course every software
technology architecture that you can
pick has its advantages and
disadvantages
I already mentioned one of them which is
if you want to even make a very small
change to your monolithic application
you have to rebuild and deploy the whole
thing tight coupling is much easier to
do in an application I just met a
gentleman whose team has a four 400
project
Visual Studio project solution and uh
you know it's really easy to do that
when you're building a monolith to have
too much code that all relies very
tightly on each other instead of keeping
them separated
um
typically you have to use the same
technology stack you might not be
thinking of that as a disadvantage you
might have a team that all kind of knows
the same technology stack maybe they
were hired because of that technology
stack now so maybe that's not a problem
for your team but if you have a large
organization with lots of different
departments lots of different areas of
technical expertise then having to use
the same technology stack for the entire
application can be a downside
it's not quite as agile of a process to
build a monolith as it can be to to
build a good healthy micro service and
it also doesn't allow you to have small
teams that are focused just on very
specific areas as much as a microservice
typical monolith is going to look
something like this the front end is
going to have multiple clients maybe
multiple different form factors they're
going to be hitting some sort of a
middle tier it's going to be like a web
server an API server and then that
server is going to be accessing some
sort of database store it might be a
relational database might be nosql
database but this is a pretty typical
uh monolithic application so when you
update the application you're basically
updating these two parts of the
application right
you can scale these I mentioned uh the
number one reason I hear people say that
they're building a microservices but
actually end up building a distributed
monolith the thing that started them out
down that path is they wanted something
scalable so I always wanted to start the
stock by saying remember monoliths are
scalable too you can scale by adding
more memory more
processor power lots of you know more
cores lots of different Hardware changes
you can make or virtual Hardware changes
you can make to that middle tier to make
it more performant you can also do the
same thing at the database tier right if
that's your bottleneck you can add more
performance there by adding more memory
that often helps the database adding
more processing power that often helps
the database as well so you can scale
this don't forget too that there is
other ways to scale
a monolith the most common way is
something that I'm sure you're familiar
with it's called load balancing
and that's where you just basically make
a multiple copies of your application
tier so here we've got two copies of our
mid middle tier and
um you know in this case you're going to
get not quite twice the performance out
of your application as you would with
just the one application server
keep in mind it's not quite because
there's the overhead of the load
balancer and so there's some loss there
and then also keep in mind that if the
bottleneck is not your application but
is actually your database there that
this is going to cause you're still
going to have performance issues here
until you deal with the database layer
which is also possible if you're having
more of your bottleneck in your database
layer you can solve that by doing
something called data sharding right and
this is still a very this is something
you would also you could also use in a
microservice but in a monolith you can
use this just as well and that's
basically where you take your data and
you split it based off of some key most
common way you would do this is if you
have a tenant like a multi-tenant
application so maybe each of these
databases is a different client maybe
database one has client a b and c and
maybe client D is a much bigger client
they have a lot more data and so you put
client B in their own database but
that's basically the client ID in that
case would be your key that's being used
to Shard this data so there's lots of
different options and I want to just
remind you that if you're trying to
build an application that scales that
doesn't necessarily mean that you have
to build microservices
okay so now hopefully we're on the same
page about what a distributed I'm sorry
what a monolith is let's talk now about
microservices so this is an architecture
that is defined uh where the software is
composed of small and Loosely coupled
services and those Services communicate
with each other through some sort of
well-defined messages on the back end
and then typically those are owned by
small and swell contained teams I'm
going to talk about that last point a
little bit more as we're going today
because that's one that surprises a lot
of people to actually be in the
definition of a microservice
some of the Hallmarks and advantages of
a microservice is that you can see these
independently deployed right so you can
have a button that you need to update
that's in just one module or some logic
that you want to update in one module
you can release that module without
having to even really communicate with
any of the teams that are running any of
the other modules they're all really
totally separate and independent
applications and so they can be deployed
independently it allows you to do more
precision scalability
I just finished my last Point saying you
can scale a monolith but you can also
scale microservices with a little bit
more Precision what do I mean by that if
you have your application split up into
multiple micro services and one of them
takes let's say 80 percent of the
traffic compared to the others you can
actually scale that one up you know with
its own Hardware to a larger degree than
what the other ones are scaled up to
allow that one to perform better without
having to scale up the ones that are
already performing fine with the lower
level of Hardware that they're running
on so a little bit more Precision with
that high availability is another one if
you architect uh microservices correctly
you can actually take down one of the
services and all of the other services
will be not even aware of the fact that
the other service is down we'll just
continue to work
on without any problems so if you
imagine if you are writing software for
a hotel chain and they want to have a
reservation service that's up 24 by
seven
you can go ahead and put that into one
microservice and now when you have let's
say the housekeeping
module for that Hotel chain when that
needs to go down for some maintenance
it's not going to affect the ability for
for that business to take reservations
because they're totally separate from
each other
uh it encourages you to write Loosely
coupled code just because your whole
application is Loosely coupled and it
also allows you to do more agile team
processes and have teams that are
experts on just different areas of your
application so especially useful if you
have a very large application not
everybody has to understand the whole
thing they can kind of focus in on
different areas and be experts in it
typical architecture for a microservices
project is going to look something like
this you're going to have your clients
usually they're going to be hitting some
sort of an API Gateway I'm not going to
go into a lot of detail about these but
usually these are used to consolidate
all of your all of your service
different microservices together for a
particular application it might also be
doing some things like security some
other cross-cutting concerns for your
application but that will kind of
consolidate all the requests and then
divvy them out to the various
microservices which you see here are in
each of the different columns
now very importantly I want you to
notice on this diagram that each of
these Services has its own application
and its own database
that's pretty important in a micro
Services architecture we're going to
talk more about that as we go and then
the last thing you see on this diagram
at the bottom is something called an
event bus
there's different ways that you can do
messaging in microservices application
this is probably the most common way
some sort of a service bus or event bus
there's lots of different tools that
implement this for you I always tell
somebody if you're starting out with
microservices this is like a really cool
nerdy problem to solve to try and create
your own event bus and you wouldn't
believe how many teams maybe you can
relate to this maybe you already feel in
your heart that it would be really fun
to build an event bus
don't build your own event bus
it's uh it seems really simple and it is
on the surface but there's a lot of
complications in there like retries and
stuff that you don't want to have to
worry about use one of the ones like
Kafka or the ones in Azure or AWS that
are pre-built for you this is the way
though that each of these services are
going to communicate with each other
typically this would be like a publish
And subscribe model where each service
would say hey I want to know whenever
this type of an event happens and then
when that event gets published by one of
the other services they would already be
subscribed to it and they would get the
update from that event so this is
typically what uh microservices is going
to look like let's talk about the bad
guy from our story today this is the
distributed monolith
this is when you start out trying to
create a microservice so first of all I
want to say nobody sets out to create a
distributed monolith right not unless
they're sadistic but
if you set out to build microservices
but you accidentally create it much more
coupled because maybe you've got Decades
of experience building monoliths like I
do maybe that's what you know best and
you know how to do that and you know all
the rules I'm not supposed to repeat
myself right I'm supposed to have single
responsibility principle all these good
rules that still apply in some ways to
microservices but there's little tweaks
to how you need to think about them when
you set out to build microservices but
you have that high coupling in your code
between your modules you're going to
probably end up with a distributed
monolith
the reason I want to warn you about
these and and why the title of this talk
is don't build a distributed monolith is
that these always perform worse than
either the monolith or the microservices
architecture this is what you might call
the worst of Both Worlds you're going to
get a much more difficult to maintain
application than it would be if it was
just a monolith
but it's going to perform worse than
either the monolith or the microservices
would
so please don't build this
we're trying to avoid that today
okay so what is a typical architecture
for a distributed monolith looks like
I purposely Drew this this way so that
it would be kind of obvious what the
problem is here the hand-drawn red
arrows here all these arrows between the
different modules whether it's from the
application to the database of a
different module or application tier to
application tier or even database to
database you could say depending on how
you do it could create problems here so
we really these red arrows are what we
want to avoid now I didn't put on this
side a an API layer I'm sorry an event
bus layer but most of the
implementations I see for uh that end up
being a distributed monolith do have an
event bus layer and what they've
basically done is in addition to using
that to communicate they've also added
these red arrows these red arrows start
out as a small exception and you know
how this goes right you're all Engineers
by the time you get to the date of
launch all those red arrows are the main
way that the applications are
communicating with each other and the
event bus is just used occasionally
uh so Crossing that line and starting
with those red arrows is often where the
problem happens
here's another architecture diagram for
a distributed monolith I can tell from
the looks every time I give this talk I
can tell from the looks on people's
faces who has this one at work so I
won't call you out and turn you in
uh but this is probably the most common
distributed monolith architecture that I
see and the it starts out very
innocently uh probably a lot of us have
a database person on our team database
administrator database developer or
something like that someone who's
basically in charge of the database
maybe a whole team that's in charge of
the database right they've learned for
decades they've been taught not to make
multiple copies of data to normalize
data to have one piece of data in one
place so that you don't end up with
update anomalies all of that good stuff
about data normalization right they've
had that beat into their heads for
decades now in in the software industry
and now here comes you after a
conference saying hey database team
wouldn't it be fun to make a mom to make
a micro service
by the way that means that we're going
to need a ton of different databases
that you're going to have to administer
oh and also we're going to copy data all
over the place it's going to be in
multiple places it's going to take a
long time for it to all update it's
going to have to propagate throughout
the application to get all of the
different databases updated whenever
something changes that's shared between
them and most good database teams that
have been doing monoliths for years are
going to say you can do whatever you
want in that middle tier you can have
fun do that cool microservices
architecture that you learned at the
conference but you're not touching my
database right
and so what ends up happening is the
application tier people that team will
do a microservices architecture but the
database team won't allow them to do and
they might say well we'll just not we'll
just make different tables we'll maybe
use a schema to separate them so that we
can kind of tell which schema goes with
which database with which application
but we'll store them all in the same
database and it'll still be kind of a
micro service but as soon as you do that
then these applications can access each
other's data stores then you start
getting coupling between these modules
so with those three different types of
applications I want to add a fourth one
which is called a modular monolith and I
want to differentiate that from the
distributed monolith that we were just
talking about and a Third Kind which I
have a high confidence that's that many
of us in the room have worked on before
which I'm going to call the ball of mud
monolith
and you know you worked on a ball of mud
monolith when you go to fix a bug in the
code you make one simple change and fix
that one bug test it everything looks
good you deploy it and it broke five
other things
right this is where there's so much
coupling in the code
so much you know bad practices going on
that you can't fix everything without
breaking everything else
that's a ball of mud monolith I think
usually when you're in one of these
microservices talks you hear people talk
about the monolith it's kind of the bad
guy in those stories right because
they're saying here's microservices
architectures and what they're good at
and when you're talking about the
monolith they'll say here's monoliths
and what they're bad at and oftentimes
you know when you're when you're
comparing and contrasting it's helpful
to compare and contrast to like the
worst case scenario I think often what
they're talking about is actually that
ball of mud monolith there is such a
thing as a good monolith that's where
you've created the code very modularly
you can make updates without breaking
other things it's really easy to read
and understand the code new people join
the team and they get up to speed fairly
quickly those are all the types of
things that indicate that you've got a
modular monolith
now you'll notice that those two types
of monoliths plus the distributed
monolith and the true microservices I've
graphed here with a couple of axes
the first axis the vertical one is how
physically separated they are so on the
bottom we've got a mod you know not
separated monolithic on the top we've
got that they're distributed and then
along the bottom I've got how logically
separated they are so we've got modular
I'm sorry monolithic logically meaning
that the whole application is written in
a way where there's High coupling
between the modules and then very
modular on the right hand side
so what you notice here is that the ball
of mud monolith
is written in a highly coupled way a
monolithic logically application and
it's deployed as a single application
so the problem isn't the fact that it's
deployed as a single application
necessarily there are some downsides to
that availability for example but the
problem is the fact that it's actually
monolithic logically
right that's what makes the ball of mud
bad and the way you fix that if you want
to leave it as a monolith is to make it
a modular Model S refactor the code so
that the the different modules within
the code have more healthy relationships
with each other
the same is true of the distributed
monolith and true microservices if you
set out to build microservices but you
couple everything together you're going
to end up with a distributed monolith if
you truly keep things separate that's
where you end up with the true
microservices
okay so now we've talked about kind of
the definitions hopefully we're on the
same page about all of those things if
you came in here not knowing what I
meant by a distributed monolith
hopefully you understand now
so now I want to talk about the 10
pitfalls that I see that are the most
common
uh that cause a microservice to
accidentally become a distributed
monolith monster
all right so problem number one I've
alluded to this one already a couple
times and problem number one is assuming
that microservices are always better
now I'm not going to accuse all of you
because you look very smart uh I'm not
going to accuse you of this but
sometimes Engineers can get caught up in
the new cool architectures and want to
do them on their project whether they're
a good fit for their project or not
right none of you I can tell from your
faces none of you know what I'm talking
about but some of the people you work
with right who aren't here today do this
uh this is especially true for smart
people like you and I really mean this
sincerely who come to a conference and
want to learn new things right you're
here to learn new things you're going to
hear probably somebody talk about how
great microservices are and I would
agree with that sentiment microservice
is a great architecture for what it's
good at but if you don't need
microservices and you use it it's going
to be just like anything else that isn't
the right tool for the job if you're
trying to open a can of soda and you're
using a hammer
that's not going to be the best tool for
that job and you're going to make a real
mess
so my first rule for microservices is
don't assume that it's necessarily the
right thing for your project unless you
have
what Sam Newman calls a really good
reason anybody familiar with Sam Newman
Sam Newman in the room he's actually
here at the conference with us
no okay he didn't want to admit it
anyway
um he is actually talking tomorrow so if
you uh if you want to learn more about
microservices he has a talk tomorrow
he's written a lot of really great stuff
about microservices so you all are very
lucky that he's kind of here in your own
backyard
um
having a really good reason though is
what he says and there's lots of bad
reasons there's a few good reasons
hopefully by the end of this talk you'll
be able to tell those apart
things I want to underscore here though
are that monoliths aren't necessarily
bad and they are scalable
microservices are really hard to do so
if you have a whole team of people that
are excited to do microservices but
nobody on the team has ever built one
successfully before your chances of
success are a bit lower than I would
like them to be if I was your boss I
would say let's not maybe take that big
of a risk or let's try and bring
somebody into the team who has some
experience with this so that we don't
make lots of mistakes because it is very
easy to do
uh also if you create them for the wrong
reason you're going to end up with this
distributed monolith instead of
microservices which I mentioned before
is going to be the worst of Both Worlds
um some good reasons to create
microservices
another person who's who speaks a lot
about microservices is James Lewis and
he says that microservices architectures
buy you options and what does he mean by
that well it gives you some options like
independent deployability we talked
about that already it gives you options
like scalability that you don't have in
a monolith more Precision in your
scalability
however it does it as a trade-off that's
what the buy that's why I've highlighted
the buy word there you have to trade
something to get something
and uh
this is what you have to trade if you
only remember one thing from The Talk
today I hope this is it because this is
the I think the most important piece of
information in here if you've never
built microservices before
microservices are inherently High
availability but they are inherently low
consistency or or eventual consistency
as it's called
monoliths are very good at immediate
consistency which is what I was
referring to earlier as data throughput
and really bad at
High availability so if you uh if you
have a project that really needs
immediate consistency and you're trying
to make microservice to do it it's
probably not going to be a good fit and
you're going to be going uphill the
whole time similarly if you if you need
a project if you need your project to be
highly available if you need to be able
to take modules down for maintenance
while other modules stay online and you
build that as a monolith you probably
already know if you've built a monolith
like that before but that's not going to
be a very good fit for your needs
so this is what I would say is maybe the
most important consideration when you're
thinking about having a good reason
the problem number two I wanted to
mention is shared data using shared data
store or shared data models this is a
common problem that I see
this is basically what happens when
especially when you're using this
particular architectural diagram that I
showed earlier where you're sharing the
database
so what happens here is that the first
module
needs to make some sort of a breaking
change to one of their tables let's say
changing a column type changing a column
name something like that
if that table is shared or if it's
available to be shared to other modules
there's a chance hopefully at the
beginning you know you start you set out
to not do this but at some point
somebody over here who doesn't know
better or hopes that they get away with
it is going to actually write some code
that accesses that table whether you
intend them to or not eventually that
will happen at oops at that point that
person just broke that application or
that application just broke unbeknownst
to that team when the first team went in
and changed something
so this is how these end up being
coupled together just by sharing the
same data store the same goes for if
you're if you're using data models like
classes that actually store your data
and you actually share those so that
that you know maybe downloads from your
git repository and the same and the
projects are using the same git
repository for that data model the same
thing happens if someone makes a change
to the data model pushes it into that
shared git repository now the next time
um you you download that and try and
build your other microservice it is
going to not work anymore and hopefully
you'll get a build error at least in
that case but as you can see in this
case if you actually changing your data
store you're not probably going to get
any build errors you're just going to
get runtime errors
example using my hotel example from
before so if you imagine that you have a
bunch of different Hotel microservices
including reservations maintenance and
housekeeping plus a couple others
if you were doing that in a monolith you
would want to store anything that was
true about a room in the hotel you'd
want to store that into a single entity
that would probably be in a single model
in your code and probably in a single
database in your I'm sorry in a single
table in your database might look
something like this where you have a
Boolean to tell you whether or not the
room is currently occupied number of
beds that are in that room how long it
takes to clean that room in minutes
maybe some related entities some like
child entities like the repair history
for that room might be in there and
that's typically how you would do it in
a monolith
now imagine you're doing that in a
shared database
and the maintenance I'm sorry the
housekeeping team comes in and says you
know we don't really care about
uh how many seconds it takes to clean a
room we're really more just interested
in the number of minutes let's go ahead
and change that from a float to an INT
and now
if this data model is used by multiple
microservices within your application
now you've just broken the other ones
that are also using that so in this case
the reservations and the maintenance
services just broke
now hopefully again that's going to
happen at um at runtime but if you've
also changed the data store to match
this type so it goes from an into a
float now that's not going to map from
your data store correctly anymore to the
maintenance and the reservations
services and you're going to get a
runtime error so either way you're
creating some pretty serious coupling
between your applications
the quote unquote correct way to do this
in microservices to actually separate
those properties out and so that each
module gets its own properties
and that it owns
as you can see here I've made a nice
perfect example that doesn't have any
complications with it you notice that
none of them need to be shared so I
created a very nice happy path example
here and you might be wondering what
happens Jay when you do need to share a
property between them
so imagine that there I've now added an
admin Service as the second one so
that's where you go to create a new room
there's been a an addition to the hotel
and you have some rooms that you need to
add so you go into the admin module and
you add some new rooms you create those
in the admin module in its database as a
hotel room with a room number
that room number is something that
you're probably going to need in all of
the different micro Services right but
it's going to be owned here by this
admin module so what does that look like
well in a microservice that's Loosely
coupled that's going to send an event to
the event bus
anything that has subscribed to that
event which let's say all three of these
other services have subscribed to the
hotel room update event or hotel you
know create update event
they're going to subscribe to that event
they're going to get an event
notification from the event bus and
they're going to have a chance to run
some of their own code
which in this case means that they're
probably going to basically add their
own copy of that hotel room to their
data store so that when this hotel room
comes up later they now have that in
there for example the reservations
service needs to know about that hotel
room so someone can reserve it
so that's that's kind of the non-happy
path if you do need to share something
that's what that might look like in a
microservice
problem number three that I see is
microservices that are too big
there's this whole field called domain
driven development is anybody familiar
with that already okay quite a few of us
um it's complicated for those that uh
that rose raised your hand just now you
know this domain driven development is a
huge topic we could talk for many hours
just about this so instead of talking
about domain driven development and how
that applies to microservices here I'll
mention a really good book to start with
which is this domain driven design book
if you want to understand how to
architect a microservices application I
highly recommend that you learn about
domain driven design or DVD for short
and that this book is a really good
place to to learn that from however if
you would like a shortcut version of it
let me explain what my shortcut version
is which is my simple rule instead of
all the stuff that you need to know from
DDD is that you're trying to create the
smallest possible microservices without
chatty communication between them now
smallest and chatty are up for debate
right those are not
measurable terms
but basically if you think of it as a
balancing arm on one side you've got how
big the service is and on the other side
you have how much that service needs to
send events to other services
if that event has to send lots of
everything it does it has to send events
to have other services do things that
might be too chatty if
it's too and it might be too small
excuse me it might be too small
if uh if it's doing that and if it's too
big then it's not sending an event ever
right it's never sending an event to do
anything anywhere else it's basically a
monolith pretending to be a microservice
the opposite problem of that is true as
well I see sometimes services that are
too small so if you imagine a scenario
where you said okay
Jay said not to make the services too
big it's called microservices right I'm
going to make them as micro as I can I'm
going to take every end point and it's
going to be its own service what could
possibly go wrong
well imagine this scenario where you've
got some sort of like user maintenance
module here and you've got a login and a
password reset and you've made those two
endpoints totally separate services from
each other well these are going to have
to communicate to each other a lot every
time you do a password reset that's
going to have to communicate to the
login service so that the new password
is there maybe if you have like a
lockout password reset after a certain
number of failures the login service is
also going to have to communicate to the
password reset module to tell how many
uh how many attempts there's been
there's going to be a lot of
communication between these two they're
always going to be updating indirectly
hopefully updating each other's data
stores
and so this is probably too chatty these
services are too small
so uh
the solution in this case would be to
combine those obviously into a single
user service and to have these be two
different endpoints in that same service
problem
number five is starting from scratch
uh
now Engineers always like to start from
scratch right who prefers Brownfield
projects to Greenfield projects okay
there's two people who love pain in the
room
um
no actually maybe those two people are
smarter than the rest of us because
actually starting from scratch is much
harder in some ways
let's talk about how
so when you're migrating a Brownfield
project you have I believe these four
advantages if you're trying to migrate a
Brownfield project to a microservices
architecture the first one is that the
code that already exists
is basically a documentation of all the
relationships that exist between the
different entities between the different
modules
you can basically go to whoever wrote
that code or maybe there's maybe you're
the one company out of 100 that has
documentation about that code that you
could actually read
but excuse me all of that stuff exists
and you can go look at the code you can
actually look at
um like code diagrams and see oh this
relates to this entity relates to that
entity one-to-many relationship all of
those types of things are documented in
your code in your database and your
documentation that's a huge Advantage
when you're trying to make all of these
decisions about where to draw the line
between different microservices in your
application to know this thing and this
thing have a ton of relationships to
each other maybe that means that they
should go into the same microservice
service together
number two you have people to talk to
that know the system when you're doing a
green field project you're often talking
to the business right about requirements
and what what does this need to do what
are you trying to do how does this
normally work what are your current
processes
a lot of that stuff as you know you can
get wrong information there if there's a
team that's already built an application
even if it's a monolith even if it's a
ball of mud monolith they have had a lot
of those conversations they know what
they wish they had done differently in
the past they know what works and what
doesn't work about that monolith that
currently exists and you can talk to
those people of course if that's you
then there's a different problem I guess
right number three is that the system
already works why is this good it buys
you time
if you're trying to do something as
complicated as a microservices
architecture and you want to get it
right
you don't want to be always having your
boss breathing down your neck saying
when is it going to be done when's it
going to be done
how much greater would it be to have a
system that's already handling whatever
that system does to take some of the
pressure off while you work on getting
the microservices correct that's a huge
advantage
and then the last one I think is really
huge which is having a baseline to
compare to so you can actually do
you can actually measure some statistics
on your current monolithic application
if you have one already and you can
compare those as you launch different
modules as microservices you can compare
them and say what's working better
what's working worse are we doing this
correctly is it actually more highly
available than it was before are we
actually able to independently deploy
things uh is the performance any better
are we able to scale things more
precisely all of those questions you can
actually measure against something
instead of just kind of a rough guess
like yes this feels good to me or it
feels bad to me which is which is the
case if you're doing a Greenfield
project
if you are migrating a project you're
going to want to think about how you go
about doing it this is always something
that we talk about with our clients
what strategy are we going to use to
migrate an existing micro monolith to
microservice
the first one is the Big Bang this is
where you do it all at once this is
usually what this looks like is a bunch
of developers get locked into a
conference room someone slides Pizza
under the door
occasionally and says don't come out
until you're done right
um
this doesn't work very well for any kind
of medium or big size project this works
really only for small projects and
usually small projects don't really need
to be converted to microservices very
much right they're already a small
project
so I don't really recommend this
approach but it is one that I have seen
done and I've probably seen it fail more
than I've seen it succeed the other one
is an evolutionary approach you could
think of this one as also as waves so
this is the approach where you refactor
your code to be more like microservices
which makes the performance worse
probably initially and then you refactor
it again to make it perform better
then you say okay that's good now I'm
going to go back to the original app and
pull out some more modules and make the
microservices makes the performance
worse again okay now I'm going to
refactor those to make them perform
better it gets better and again right so
you keep doing that until you finished
pulling everything out and refactoring
it and you kind of get this wave effect
of things getting better worse better
worse
the last one is called the Strangler fig
pattern if anybody heard of this one for
other things yeah okay good so for those
that haven't heard of it before it's
pretty simple this is where you create
like a facade layer you could use an API
Gateway for this if you're doing
microservices and you start refactoring
things from your legacy app to your
modern app in this case it would be from
your monolith to your microservices
and you keep moving things over there as
you're moving them over you use that
facade layer or the API Gateway to make
it basically all look exactly the same
to the front end so the front end
doesn't really have to change at all
it's sort of unaware of what's going on
behind the facade layer and at some
point you finish that migration process
and everything is now in your modern
microservices app and theoretically at
that point you could get rid of the
facade although if it's an API Gateway
there's other advantages but at that
point you finished the pattern now this
comes from a Strangler fig plant which
as I understand actually grows it's
dropped by birds and grows starting in
the limbs of a tree as a Vine it grows
down the tree and eventually it gets
down to the base of the tree and wraps
around the roots of the tree underground
that eventually chokes the life out of
that tree the tree dies and it becomes
just like a backbone for the vine now
it's giving the Divine access to the
sunlight up high without the vine really
having to do any of that work building
that trunk
but the tree is now dead and has
basically turned into something new so
it's kind of a sounds kind of a nasty
little plant if you like trees but it's
a great approach for migrating your
application from one technology to
another
uh number six now is coupling through
cross-cutting concerns there's a lot of
cross-cutting concerns in our
applications one example of that though
is logging
and I highly recommend that you use
logging into microservices along any
application but especially in a
microservices application because it's
so much harder to tell what's happening
in a microservices application if you
imagine that you're trying to debug a
particular scenario where somebody goes
in hits one endpoint in microservice a
microservice a publishes an event
microservice B subscribes to that event
does some update maybe that's where the
bug happens updates its database wrong
and now all you know is that
microservice B has some incorrect data
in its data store and you don't really
know how it happens and it's pretty hard
to go back and Trace all of those things
that happened so logging is very
important but also if you write a single
logging module and share that into all
your applications you actually have the
potential to create some coupling there
for example let's say it's logging to a
database to a centralized database let's
say that database goes down now all your
modules just went down right because
your logging isn't working another
example let's say you write it it and
I'm a.net guy so let's say you write
that logging in the you know the best
platform available for developers.net
but you have another team that wants to
build a micro service module in Java or
something else
now they're kind of stuck they can't use
your logging because it's only in.net
right so you've you've coupled the whole
team to using a particular Tech stack as
well
there's a lot of great Solutions out
there so just be aware of anytime you're
doing a cross-cutting concern that you
might want to look to see what the best
practice is I've given you an example
here of a good tool to use for logging
it's called seek seq
and it's inherently
distributed so it expects to be working
as a distributed application it's
inherently fault tolerant it's got
support for basically any platform or
language that you've ever heard of
so it doesn't tie you into a particular
Tech stack
and it Embraces that eventual
consistency that is the watchword of
microservices
so be careful when you're doing things
like logging make sure you do these
things still but make sure that you're
doing something that is compatible with
microservices architecture and doesn't
accidentally create coupling
number seven the use of synchronous
communication
let's take an example here where you've
got two modules and orders
module and a customers module
let's say the orders module takes a
couple of parameters uh it's a it's
receiving a new order
it's going to get like all the details
of the order and then maybe it's going
to also get like a customer ID let's say
it's like an integer or a good or
something that just identifies a
customer and says this customer is
ordering these items in these quantities
the very first thing that order service
is going to have to do is figure out who
this customer is now if you've gone and
just left that customer data only in
your customer service you might be
really tempted to do something like this
where maybe you do like a rest API call
from your orders service over to your
customers service and say why don't you
just give me customer ID one two three
four five
and while that's processing this order
service right these are this is a
synchronous call it's a rest API uh it's
waiting for that data to come back over
here from the customer's data store
while that's waiting the order service
is also waiting right now
in the best case scenario that data
comes back and says here's the details
about that customer and the orders
processing can continue uh with you know
the mailing address and whatever
it needed from the customer
now imagine that the customer service
goes down for maintenance and your order
comes in with an order the order details
and the customer ID now this call
basically fails immediately it gets a
maybe a 500 or some other kind of you
know response that indicates that it's
not available
and now your order service actually went
down as well
or imagine another scenario where the
customer service is under heavy load
maybe somebody's going through and
creating a bunch of new customers maybe
that's a process that happens every
month or every year or something there's
a bunch of load going on in this
application now when this order service
gets a new order in it's not under any
load or maybe it's just under its normal
load everything is processing pretty
normally but now it has to wait three
times as long four times as long for the
or for the customer service to respond
now your order service just got slow
because your customer service was low so
are those really decoupled are those
independent from each other are you able
to Precision scale them not really
because if the customer service slow the
order service is slow now that story I
told you at the beginning of this talk
about a customer that asked us to help
with their application they had hundreds
of these in between every microservice
and every other microservice basically
making it a very slow monolith right
every time anything happened instead of
just executing the code from that other
module that needed to be executed they
made a rest HTTP call now you all
probably know there's a lot more
overhead with that than just executing
in this case it was net c-sharp code
there's a lot more overhead in that than
just making a procedure call in a
programming language like c-sharp and so
their whole application got very slow
furthermore because these arrows were
between every module and every other
module what would end up happening is
one module would get slowed due to
actual load which would cause the three
that called it to get slow which would
cause those three to slow down the nine
that modules that called it and it only
took about a minute every time one
module got slow for the whole
application to get slow
uh and so this is a very dangerous one
that you definitely want to avoid number
eight is breaking changes to event
contracts you if you haven't done event
uh events before if you haven't done
microservices before you might have
already been thinking boy those events
kind of end up being like a coupling
between the modules right and that's
true which means you have to have some
rules uh and you have to probably do
some thinking and maybe even some
communicating between different teams to
figure out what these rules are going to
be and make sure everyone's doing the
same thing in the different service
applications
uh these are some rules that I suggest
just as a starting point and then
obviously you need to have this
discussion with all the different teams
but number one is that no new required
Fields only optional Fields with
documented default values
well what do you do when you need to do
that
um
we'll talk about that in Rule Number
Four
rule number two is that any unrecognized
field will just be ignored but forwarded
right so if you have a service that is
going to process some event subscribing
to some event it sees a new field that
it's never seen before it should just
ignore that it apparently that's a new
field that it didn't need to know about
right because it didn't exist when it
was created but it should forward it in
other words if it actually publishes an
event of its own after it does something
it should forward that information on to
anyone else that might be subscribed
because there might be some other
microservice that does know what that is
that needs it and so ignore but forward
rule number three
consumers of optional Fields use default
values when they're missing right so if
you are subscribing to an event and
someone is publishing that event that
doesn't know about a field that you need
there has to be some sort of a default
value for that field and that's what you
should assume the value is
and then number four is if you can't do
these first three then you need to
create a whole new event type so you
might have this isn't the naming
convention I would suggest but if you
started with a
to use our example from before if you
started with a room updated event you
might make this your room updated event
too right like you actually have to
create a new event for this to make
breaking changes and now any service
that publishes the event too is also
going to have to publish the original
event for anybody that's still
subscribed to that
problem number nine that I see is not
automating builds and releases I'm sure
none of you are doing this but I've seen
a lot of our clients who you know still
haven't gotten into the whole automated
CI CD devops thing and they come to us
and say hey we heard about microservices
we think it might be a good fit for our
application we'd like to do those one of
the very first questions I well the very
first question I ask them is why
microservices why is that a good fit for
your project just to try and hear if I
hear any of the false things that I've
been talking about with you all today or
if I hear any of the true good reasons
you mentioned in there but then maybe
the second thing I will ask them is do
you already have automated devops
continuous integration continuous
deployment in your in your application
or not the reason is because the whole
point one of the whole points of
microservices is high availability and
uh and the ability to independently
deploy
so the idea is that you might want to be
able to deploy pretty frequently
and if you're doing that manually that's
obviously
very time consuming very prone to error
so I always say as a prerequisite if you
haven't
um if you haven't done cicd already as
an automated process
please consider doing this first before
you start doing microservices you'll
thank me later
number 10 is unencapsulated services
this is really just another way of
saying
um
is talking about coupling loose coupling
versus
too high coupling
so you might have heard this analogy
before that a well-defined defined
service is kind of like an iceberg you
know that old saying that ninety percent
of an iceberg is below the water line
and only 10 of it is above
the same kind of goes for your API as a
well-designed API whether it's for
microservices or not is going to have a
very small surface area that is above
the water line and a much larger
implementation what's great about this
is that you can make you can make
changes
to the implementation layer you can
refactor things all you want you can
change how you're storing things you can
change what events you're publishing all
of that stuff can change pretty
frequently and you're not breaking
anything
from that API this also I would say
applies to events to the events that you
publish as well
now if you lower that water line
you can imagine that now anytime you
make a change in the back end it's
likely that you're going to have to make
a change in the front end too so simple
single purpose apis that just do one
thing that are very unlikely to have
their signatures change is going to make
your life a lot easier whether that's an
event
or whether that's like a rest API
whatever it is if you're doing
microservices designing those API as
well is going to make a big difference
so think about that and maybe take a
little extra time as you're designing
them
bonus problem we made it through the 10
that I promised you and now you're
getting a free one totally free of
charge
extra which is mismatched teams
so remember you got a free bonus Pitfall
here when you're rating it with the
cards on your way out okay
that moves you up one card I think is
the rule so what do I mean by small
teams or mismatched teams
there we go there's a law called
Conway's law that you may have heard
before it's often talked about in
engineering
it says that any organization that
designs a system will produce a design
whose structures a copy of the
organization organization's
communication structure what does that
mean basically it means that whatever
your team builds is going to look like
your org chart
right so the common example that's given
of that is if you give a team of
Engineers if you get four teams of
Engineers the job to build a compiler
they're going to create a four pass
compiler what does that mean that
basically means that there's going to be
four unique steps because there's no
team that's going to basically say oh
our contribution to this compiler is
actually handled perfectly by the other
three teams so just ignore us just throw
away what we built right every team is
going to say no ours is important to
make sure that you do that so you're
going to end up with four steps to that
process
how does that apply to microservices
well if you have a single team that's
working on multiple microservices
uh and everyone kind of swatched swapped
around to all of those as needed you're
probably going to end up with a product
that looks an awful lot like that team
you're probably going to end up with a
more monolithic product because everyone
knows everything else it's going to be
more tempting for a team member who used
to be working on module a but it's now
working on module B to know that module
a has some data that they want and to be
tempted to go straight and get that data
Maybe to copy and paste some code maybe
to make some of the decisions about the
tech Stacks that are used on these
different services so that people can be
swapped in and out of them basically
it's going to cause your application to
Veer in the direction of a monolith
so instead of having a single team that
works on all your microservices an ideal
setup would be to have one team work on
each micro service if these if you have
a huge application complicated business
this can actually be really ideal
because each of these teams can be an
expert in each particular module in each
part of your business they don't really
have to care about what's happening in
the other parts as long as those teams
are working
but
um obviously this isn't totally
practical you may not even have this
many people on your team
so you know I don't think it's super
important that it'd be a hundred percent
but just keep in mind that if you go 100
this way
that it's going to probably bump your
application more into the monolithic
Direction than you intend
but if you do something like this where
you share uh one team maybe shares a
couple different modules that's not
going to be the end of the world
especially if they're always working on
those two modules
all right so to sum up a little bit uh
we talked about for lightweight
applications that have a single team a
monolithic system might suit you better
or more complex and evolving
applications with clear different
domains between them to use the DVD
terminology
and if you want to use separate teams
that are experts in those different
areas then microservices might be the
best best the best bet
don't do microservices unless you have a
really good reason to do it because
monoliths can be good too especially if
they're a good fit for your project
and then finally to avoid those 10 plus
1 free
pitfalls that we just talked about
so some further reading
if you're interested in learning more
uh
these three books here is where I would
start a couple of these are by Sam who I
think writes the best stuff about
microservices and then we also have this
one by Chris Richardson which is a good
starting point
uh then I would also recommend these
books as well Cloud native architectures
and the Dao of microservices
so we defined monoliths microservices
and distributed monoliths talked about
those 10 Common pitfalls plus the bonus
one
give you some further reading now I've
just got a few minutes if anybody has
any questions they'd like to ask any
burning questions in the room
yes
is
um yeah yeah so the question if I
understood correctly is uh I talked a
little bit about the migration patterns
and how do you do that at the database
level is that correct
uh so one of the things that hopefully
you noticed in the talk was that you're
going to end up with some repeated data
into different modules if you end up
going in the micro Services Direction so
one of the options that you have is when
you do kind of cut over to your first
microservice going live is that you're
probably going to have to do a data
migration project of some kind to get
that data initially loaded in there or
you could use the event bus to just very
busily for a little while load data in
there either way works obviously one is
faster than the other but at some point
you're going to have duplicated data
anyway so you're really going to start
out by duplicating some data into there
that you need you'll also have to think
through if in the in between this is
another question I commonly get that's
kind of related to your question which
is in that in between stage when you
start going from a monolith to a
microservice aren't you basically
creating a distributed monolith and the
answer is yes I think that's unavoidable
just you know be careful of stopping
there but hopefully that answers your
question about databases did it
cool other questions
yes in the front here yeah you mentioned
that there is a problem if you add more
experience to events can you elaborate
sure sure yeah so the question is about
changing your event signatures
specifically adding Fields so adding
Fields isn't necessarily a problem as
long as you write all of your event
handling code to expect event uh expect
properties to be added to your events
the big problem is if you remove one
change the name of one change the type
of one right any breaking change like
that that's the really big thing adding
is okay as long as you kind of look at
those rules that I listed before the
four rules if you assume that a property
is that's not there
is a default value you have a particular
default value all the new properties you
add have to be optional because
obviously they may not be there for
everything
anything that breaks those rules that
needs to have a new property there or
needs to change the name of a property
that's just a new event type
yep
yeah
there should be a UK religion as well
right I mean because they're very
similar in the position for the
distributed monolith you're saying okay
so if I understood the question
correctly it's uh there's a use case for
the monolith there's a use case for the
microservice is there a use case for the
distributed monolith the way I'm
defining it at least in this talk the
distributed monolith is kind of the
worst of Both Worlds of each and so no
there really isn't long term
thank you very much we're out of time
but I'm happy to answer any questions if
you want to come up afterwards and uh
appreciate your time thank you